I want you all to hear this  at 1202 a.m Pacific Standard Time when  the contiguous United States is now  completely within November 8th the day  of the midterm there will be a beginning  again at 1202 a.m a blood moon a full  moon total blood lunar eclipse it's when  the moon starts turning red  for those on the East Coast between 5 17  and 6 45 or so you will see a blood red  moon  now the Incans and the Mesopotamians  believed that a Blood Moon signified the  death of the king and the overthrow of  his regime I kid you not  this is crazy so that that one has meal  just like you know I don't know I don't  know if I believe in the Omens or  anything but the overthrow of the king  Revolution a red wave perhaps not of  establishment Republicans but of Maga  Republicans so people are calling it The  Maga Moon